In fact, this is a really important point. The
browser can't really tell that it's definitively online. It
can't tell that it's definitively offline either, unless it
really has no connection to another device at all.
In fact there's an attribute, navigator.onLine, that supposedly tells
you whether you're online or not. There's also a
pair of events that fire up the body of
the document when you go online or offline. However,
I don't recommend relying on these, they really just tell
you if there's a network connection or not, they don't
tell you if that network connection is actually connected to
anything. For example, my computer at home is occasionally fooled
because my cable modem will go out, but my computer
is still connected to the router. Sometimes, computers or applications
will use pings to various servers to tell them if
there's a connection to the internet. But fundamentally, as a developer
the only offline status that matters to you is can
you get to your own servers, and of course in the
cellular radio case it can be even more complex we've all
had the experience of having a one bar signal. And trying
to use the network. In fact, this is a critical
point to offline use, and why we say you need to
build offline first. You might think the way to support offline
is to use the network first and then if it fails
you can rely on the cash, but that doesn't
really work in the real world. Precisely because it can
take a long time to determine, if you don't
really have an internet connection. If you only offer cache
data once a network request has difinitively failed, you
leave users waiting while their device desperately tries, but fails
to actually transfer data over the network. This is what
we mean by offline first, not that you should code
offline first, but to underscore that your app has
to be able to use cache data first. And then
update the cache contents when it's online, but continue
to use old data from the cache when it's offline.